it's not something you'd want to see on
a first date whether it be ghosts or the
truly vile meals the cast was subjected
to there's a lot more to bones and all
than what you see on the screen let's
get into it why'd you happen to bring me
along
you seem nice
I am nice number one hopefully you
aren't squeamish well over 10 liters of
fake blood was used in production and it
was actually pretty edible the fake
blood was made using a mixture of syrup
brownies and maraschino cherries and if
that didn't sound sweet enough
production would even use Fruit Roll-Ups
for some of the gorier scenes for flesh
however they used Platinum pure silicone
which Prosthetics lead Jason Hammer
described by saying it's stolen from the
dental industry so it's safe for the
mouth you wouldn't want to chew up a
bunch of it and swallow it but you can
get in there and sell the action and
then spit take Taylor Russell has
admitted that the silicone turned the
actors off of their meals saying you
smell the rubber gross it confuses the
senses number two do you believe in
ghosts Taylor Russell does in an
interview with BuzzFeed Russell
reflected on the scene that they filmed
with Chloe 70 by saying I don't know if
the building was actually haunted but I
remember it feeling very haunted Russell
went on to explain that they filmed the
scene in an elementary school and that
there were all these stories on set that
all these tragedies happened there
Russell then went around trying to
mitigate the energies somehow admitting
that she didn't really know what she was
doing but whatever it was she felt like
it worked because it felt really strange
and Chloe brought it so heavily in that
scene it just felt so intense number
three what an awkward situation Chloe 70
has worked with director Luca guadagnino
before on the HBO series we are who we
are and so when he called her up asking
if she'd play a small but pivotal role
in his new film she apparently replied
I'll come for anything one line no lines
whatever it is but little didn't Chloe
know until she actually received the
script that her dialogue would consist
of little more than a single voiceover
line and a little bit of growling far
from being bitter about it though Chloe
would go on to say that she'd work with
Luca again while at the nyff premiere
for bones and all number four your
wardrobe says a lot about you costume
designer Julia piercanti took a piece
from her own closet for Lee's blue
floral print shirt coming up with the
back story that it was once a 30s dress
I imagined belonged to a neaten old lady
that he might have found in her closet
and he cut to fit him as a shirt which
is apparently something Lee does a lot
appropriating himself with a piece of
his victims and putting him on top of
himself Marin's costumes meanwhile are
meant to reflect piercanti's feeling
that she doesn't really have a sense of
herself as she grew up without a mother
number five hair can be a great way to
express yourself Timothy chalamet saw
Lee's dyed hair as an important part of
his character as as he sees Lee as
someone who's desperate for identity and
expressing himself lead hair designer
masimo gatabrusi said that they took
inspiration from the time period and
from icons such as Cindy Lauper while
the color red is meant to reflect the
character's energy it took them two
hours to dye his hair leaving black
roots to feel the time pass through the
hair number six would you shave your
head for a roll as it turned out Chloe
70 didn't have to instead lead hair
designer messimogata Brucie sewed a
short wig into her hair he explained
that she was shocked when she saw it but
she also understood that her hair is a
very strong instrument to change the
Identity or personality masima went on
to state that the director was excited
about the results and that Chloe was
excited about it too because it helped
her to better understand her character
she apparently took her time to truly
filo the new do number seven we all have
a story makeup department head Fernanda
Perez put plenty of thought into to the
characters backstories when it came to
the scar Prosthetics that she
meticulously placed on the actor's
bodies every day David Gordon Green's
character was given a bite on his hand
that barely even made it to the screen
although Perez explained as a backstory
that he got it when he met Jake and he
had tried to bite him Perez explained
that the scar on Sully's cheek is from a
fight with another eater while the scar
on his chin is from a bone Shard that
cut into him during a meal number eight
bones and all is a first for Luka
guadagnino you know America quite well
I've been there for many many times but
this is my first American movie while he
usually sets his films in historic
European cities this time he was filming
in the United States the movie depicts a
road trip all throughout Ronald Reagan's
America but most of the filming was
contained to the area in and around
Cincinnati Ohio guadagnino told deadline
in an interview I've been totally
influenced by the American culture
American Cinema and now American
landscape so I'm very happy and proud
that I've finally come to this Shore
number nine you have to follow your
conscience little details have been
included throughout the film to suggest
that Marin has a strong sense of
morality like showing how she feels
guilty when she has to steal to survive
you have always a moral compass Lee
meanwhile is shown to have morals but no
clear path I think Marin's a very
inspiring figure to him guaragnino has
said that the real pulling in point of
the film for him must have been how this
character would carry a moral struggle
with oneself and that Theme played a
major role in his choice to take on the
script number 10. what's the strangest
thing you've been asked to do on set
director Luca had one odd direction to
give Taylor Russell I just remember you
saying smell more on the day guadagnino
wanted to communicate that eaters can
smell one another but Russell admitted
that she didn't always know how big she
had to go to have it register on camera
meaning that she had to take some big
inhales weird but but she's used to it
as Russell told Teen Vogue I just try to
follow my instincts and that usually
leads me to very strange places which is
good number 11. do you remember the 80s
bones and all is set in 1980s America
and you can actually see a number of
props throughout the movie based on
merchandise that's no longer available
they basically created this thing it's
all original pieces from the 80s
portraying characters from before the
age of social media Taylor Russell told
Timothy chalamet that she appreciated
the beauty of boredom or something
Russell explained that she saw Marin to
be more present in the moment without
the distraction of social media and more
resourceful considering she didn't have
a phone to rely on number 12. believe it
or not this movie almost wasn't even
made bones and all marks the third
collaboration between this writer
director Duo after Suspiria and a bigger
Splash although David thought of Luca
immediately when he read the book the
director was busy with another project
at the time and so David began
production with director Antonio Campos
instead when Antonio backed out David
sensed a little window with Luca when
David practically begged Luca to read
the script he agreed and we made the
film number 13 calling all Rock Fans the
soundtrack for bones and all features
hits from bands such as New Order and
Joy Division but that isn't the only
connection the movie has to some of its
biggest musical influences according to
their director in an interview with the
rap all the graphic design in the movie
has been created by by this Sublime
artist named Peter Seville who created
in the past the album covers for New
Order and Joy Division before concluding
with we put a lot of thought into that
for all the difficulties production
faced you can plainly see how much love
and care was put into this story that
meant so much to its creators how well
do you think their ideas translated onto
screen make sure to let us know in the
comments